I find somebody that I can call and I
say hey I am overwhelmed what that does
is it helps me make me feel not alone in
my overwhelm which for some reason helps
me feel that I can sort of tackle
whatevers I'm dealing with sometimes
they'll offer me some strategies but the
best thing is also when I'm feeling
overwhelmed to recognize that overwhelm
comes from looking at everything that I
have to do and thinking how am I going
to get it all done and so my strategy
for beating overwhelmed is to not look
at everything but to look at one thing
okay I'm just going to do this one thing
think of it like a marathon it's very
hard to say I'm about to run 26 miles
absolutely overwhelming but you can say
to yourself we can say to ourselves I'm
just gonna run one mile and then you run
another mile then you do so what I find
the best solution to help me overcome
overwhelm is to actually get rid of all
the stuff that's overwhelming me and get
it to one thing that I can absolutely
take care of